die area 51 oder fifty one im us
bundesstaat nevada eine geheime
militärbasis auf der immer wieder
mysteriöse aktivitäten beobachtet werden
unzählige verschwörungstheorien oder
sind es gar keine ranken sich um diese
location und das us-militär und die
regierung halten sich bedeckt was geht
also wirklich ab ist die area fifty one
ein ufo landeplatz oder ein testgelände
für geheim jets krieg substanzen fiction
herzlich willkommen
erst einmal vielen dank für diesen
coolen dem vorschlag bei whatsapp wir da
hin kommt dass er vater am ende des
videos
vor diesem einen spektakulären abend im
mai 1989 hatte die öffentlichkeit noch
nichts von dem abgelegenen militärischen
sperrgebiet in nevada mitten im
nirgendwo gehört nur die silhouette von
dem geheimen informanten war im
fernsehinterview zu sehen schließlich
wollte dennis so nannte er sich nicht
erkannt werden ergab sich als ex
mitarbeiter der nellis air force base
aus die rund 150 kilometer vor las vegas
entfernt ist und er hatte kuriose dinge
zu berichten unter anderem von neuen
fliegenden untertassen außerirdischen
ursprungs alien raumschiffen also die er
als physiker zusammen mit anderen
forscherinnen und forschern untersucht
haben wollte
robert lasso der echte name des zeugen
wollte sich vor allem um den anti
materie antrieb der drei meter hohen
flug scheiben gekümmert haben
er sollte ihn nach bauen und so das
berichtete er später in einer
neunteiligen dokumentation auf demselben
fernsehen.de sender class tv er hatte es
auch schon einige testflüge geben lassen
behauptete außerdem dass die us
regierung hinter allem stecke und area
fifty one als location benutze um mit
einer großen grauen schweizerischen
spezies in kontakt zu treten und
technologien auszutauschen
die aliens hätten sehr kleine münder und
nasen dafür bei extrem große köpfe und
augen ja ihr könnt euch vorstellen was
diese story weltweit auslöste es gab
einen regelrechten ufo und alien haid
werden dort schlimme allen experimente
durchgeführt ist die area 5 gewann
die spielwiese für ufo tests auf unserer
erde genau diesen hype hatte die us
regierung jahrelang zu verhindern
versucht die militärbasis war lange zeit
wohl mit eines der krassesten
geheimnisse überhaupt teilweise hatte
die amerikanische regierung es sogar
bestritten dass die anlage überhaupt
existiert obwohl es sogar fotos aus dem
weltraum gab die die basis deutlich
zeigte 1994 dann ein erster hinweis dass
area 5 die wand tatsächlich existiert
existiert doch das geschah auch mehr
oder weniger not
ehemalige arbeiter hatten geklagt dass
sie auf dem stützpunkt giftige gase
eingeatmet hatten
doch bis heute sind die offiziellen
informationen die zur mädels range
herausgegeben werden mehr als dürftig in
einem statement der airforce heißt es
zitat gewisse aktivitäten und
operationen die amneris range in
vergangenheit und gegenwart durchgeführt
werden bleiben unter verschluss und
können nicht öffentlich diskutiert
werden 2013 sprach die us regierung das
erste mal offiziell von der existenz des
testgeländes sie veröffentlichte damals
geheime unterlagen in einem 400 seitigen
dokument in dem alle flugzeug tests seit
den 50er jahren aufgelistet sind doch
der mythos um area fifty one wird
bestehen bleiben dafür sorgen raketen
abfangjäger schwer bewaffnete
sicherheitsleute versteckte mikrofone
sensoren und kameras die region ist ein
militärisches sperrgebiet und
eindringlinge werden sofort festgenommen
bevor area 5 gewann zum hochsicherheits
gelände wurde diente sie als ausweich
landeplatz der airforce der
ausgetrockneten salzsee eignete sich
hervorragend als landebahn außerdem
sorgt auch das benachbarte
atombombentest gelände dafür dass sich
kaum jemand in dieser region verirrt und
so nutzen die ce und die erforscht das
gelände um die ganzen projekte überhaupt
zu testen beispielsweise die u2 ein
spionage flugzeug das für den kalten
krieg entwickeln worden war auch das
nachfolgemodell der u2 wurde je getestet
die a12 die mit dreifacher
schallgeschwindigkeit unterwegs ist
heutzutage ist sie allerdings noch mehr
los mehr als 20 anders 30 wohnhäuser und
drei start und landebahnen befinden sich
hier eine von ihnen mit rund sieben
kilometern bis zu 1500 menschen arbeiten
hier täglich
doch was genau machen sie laut den
zahlreichen verschwörungstheorien
arbeiten sie oberirdisch an
irgendwelchen militär projekten aber das
nur zur tarnung doch eigentlich soll
dort in einem riesigen tunnelsystem
unter der wüste an außerirdischen
technologien geforscht werden seriöse
expertinnen und experten bezweifeln dass
die anlage werde zwar zur erprobung
neuer technologien genutzt diese seien
allerdings alle irdisch und nicht
außerirdisch die massenhaften ufo
sichtungen in der region seien alle mit
den vielen flugzeug experimenten zu
erklären und insider behaupten sogar
dass die verantwortlichen der iaa 15
solche verschwörungstheorien inzwischen
sogar ganz lieb sein denn diese würden
die menschen von den tatsächlichen
geheim projekten ablenken
so würden ab und an auch extra
lasershows abgehalten um die ganzen uwe
jäger in der region weiter zu verwirren
und auch der zeuge von damals so etwas
lasse sich schnell als unglaubwürdig
seine angeblichen universitätsabschlüsse
waren erfunden zudem zeigten andere
physiker dass er in sachen ufo bau nur
wenig ahnung hatte später wurde er dann
auch noch in las vegas wegen zuhälterei
verurteilt er hatte eine
videoüberwachungsanlage in einem bordell
installiert also robert lover fake und
auch alle anderen videoaufnahmen und das
bildmaterial haben sich als fake
herausgestellt ehrlich gesagt weil der
area 5 die wahren kann man nicht
entscheiden was war und was fähiges hier
wird unter strengsten geheimhaltungs
bedingungen gearbeitet das gelände ist
militärisch ist wind also der
verteidigung der usa über das was da
passiert weiß nur ein kleiner
personenkreis bescheid ja man kann hier
nur glauben oder eben nicht dran glauben
ja wenn es also neue belege geben sollte
oder andere hinweise werde ich natürlich
darüber berichten und wenn er kein video
dazu und so allen anderen dem verpassen
wollt die youtube abo box funktioniert
ja einfach nicht dann endet mich bei
whatsapp nur dann verpasst ihr kein
video wie whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen andern vom neuesten video
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
zur begrüßung habe ich noch ein kleines
geschenk für euch ansonsten unbedingt
meinen schwesterkanal pixum socialmedia
abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social
media welt wie zum beispiel die
hintergründe über den volks lehrer der
an einer schule in berlin gekündigt
wurde weil er unter anderem auf youtube
verschwörungstheorien verbreitet hat
dafür auch hier klicken aber nicht
genau die glocke vergessen wie geht's
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken ufo
sichtung sehr sehr spannend bis dann
bleibt dran